[Música]
una ola de calor sin precedentes afecta
a gran parte del oeste de europa y
norteamérica las temperaturas sofocantes
han marcado récords en los últimos días
en varias naciones y solo este martes 19
de julio reino unido rompió tres veces
en un mismo día sus marcas históricas
llegó hasta los 40 punto tres grados
celsius una cifra jamás registrada en
ese territorio
francia también invitó advertencia de
calor extremo países bajo el registro
también un récord de temperaturas para
el mes de julio y en bélgica un fuego
provocado por el calor destruyó varios
vehículos y también por supuesto bosques
los incendios forestales en francia
portugal españa grecia han obligado a
miles de personas a evacuar sus hogares
y de acuerdo con los pronósticos de esta
ola de calor se va a dirigir en los
próximos días hacia el norte y se espera
que la temperatura llegue también a los
40 grados en el extremo sur de bélgica
así como en el oeste y el sur oeste de
alemania- saludamos entonces a álvaro so
para ti eres especialista en políticas
climáticas globales álvaro gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24
muy buen día que está pasando entonces
en este momento con estos calores
extremos que azotan principalmente a
europa ya también lo estamos viendo en
eeuu también en parte de canadá y como
digamos a cada día estos eventos
extremos climáticos nos van afectando y
todavía no hacemos nada concreto álvaro
muy buenos días para ti y para toda la
audiencia efectivamente esto es parte de
un fenómeno un poco más más extenso
digamos las olas de calor han existido
siempre pero en este caso están
exacerbadas por por el calentamiento
global por el cambio climático este
recordemos que con olas de calor nos
referimos a eventos de más de 3 o 4 días
de temperaturas extremas e sostenidas en
relación al promedio de la región en
cuestión así que este es el contexto que
estamos enfrentando desde hace algunas
décadas y que se encuentra en creciente
relevancia por las proyecciones que los
expertos han hecho claro digamos también
se están derritiendo los pueblos hemos
visto en italia también derretimiento se
en la nieve de las montañas como cambia
todo esto el ecosistema como eso también
digamos afecta nuestra seguridad como
también en los cambios extremos de clima
hacen que la gente emigre hacia nuevos
territorios o para huir no de estos
climas extremos súplicas en invivibles
sus territorios actuales
así es ella dando en la tecla con uno de
los temas importantes que tiene que ver
con el aumento de las el tamaño de las
ciudades y de las poblaciones que se
desplazan hacia las ciudades por razones
de diversa índole entre ellas búsqueda
de oportunidades esto hace crecer mucho
lo que se denomina la mancha urbana que
a la vez en el contexto de olas de calor
se retroalimenta este fenómeno con el
fenómeno de isla urbana de calor que es
una doble efecto de este mismo fenómeno
lo cual incrementa muchísimo más las
posibilidades de impactos en la
sobretodo la salud humana claro también
álvaro pues estábamos viendo ayer en la
nasa si no me equivoco reveló estas
imágenes de todo el mundo prácticamente
en rojo no consecuencia de este calor
extremo yo le quiero preguntar si este
calor extremo también se traduce en un
invierno extremo no qué podemos esperar
ya cuando se acerque el invierno y
también pues todas estas crisis de
energía sobre todo en europa en cuanto
al gas como podría también estar
afectado el continente europeo en ese
sentido
bien gracias por la pregunta esto
depende mucho de las décadas su región
en términos generales en muchas regiones
los inviernos van a ser un poco más más
suaves para decirlo de una manera simple
aunque puede haber días y semanas de
frío muy muy extremo como sucedió
recientemente con las olas polares en el
invierno de eeuu hace unos meses pero en
términos generales los impactos más
grandes se van a ver en el aumento de
las temperaturas sobre todo en los
veranos y sobre todo en las regiones que
están entre los trópicos eso es como lo
que más se espera en términos generales
luego cada subregión puede tener
particularidades álvaro también es
curioso porque digamos que en esta ola
de calor que ya también está afectando
gran parte de eeuu pues vimos el día
ayer en nueva york e inundaciones unas
tormentas e increíbles o sea como que
todos o todos está cambiando el clima
está impreciso ya obviamente no se puede
esperar que haga calor en una época que
haga frío en otra que llueva en otra
como como interpretar esto y además
siento que los gobiernos tampoco están
escuchando el planeta no sé por qué en
políticas digamos son macro se termina
quedando en las cumbres pero no vemos
que no se traduce realmente a la
población también álvaro lo
conversábamos en este programa en vez de
que la guerra en ucrania potencial hice
este cambio a las energías renovables
nos estamos volcando a seguir buscando
energías fósiles en petróleo eeuu
también buscando el petróleo en arabia
saudita en países árabes este
acercamiento de venezuela también en
cuanto al petróleo entonces es como un
doble mensaje de cuidemos el planeta
pero al final no lo estamos haciendo
así es el tema roble bastante complejo
porque el desarrollo económico en el
cual estamos inmersos o el patrón de
desarrollo de los patrones de producción
y consumo son altamente demandantes de
energía y en este caso mientras siga
creciendo la demanda energía va a ser
difícil hacer una transición energética
hacia energías limpias de manera rápida
a largo plazo va a suceder pero va a
demorar más tiempo eso sería a largo
plazo y esto tiene que ver con los
efectos que podemos esperar de aquí a
diez veinte treinta o más décadas
me refiero esto ya están las cuestiones
de políticas internas más coyunturales y
más inmediatas para hacer frente a estos
fenómenos que tiene que ver con la
planificación por ejemplo urbana la
política de adaptación al cambio
climático tanto bueno urbano como rural
en este caso qué es lo que sí se puede
hacer para atenuar los impactos y para
hacer un poco más resilientes a nuestros
sistemas y nuestras sociedades ese es el
otro el otro debate claro es que eso es
se le quería preguntar también álvaro
que realmente en la práctica es tan
difícil poner en práctica estas estas
energías verdes estas energías limpias
por ejemplo lo pongo
en nuestro continente en colombia el
presidente electo gustavo petro dijo que
ya quería realmente hacer esta
transición energías energías verdes ya
estaba ahí como una disputa con
ecopetrol hay analistas que dicen que
eso es un error que todavía no se puede
hacer realmente que tan difícil es
empezar a hacerlo de una vez
bueno
nuevamente es factible y es complejo al
mismo tiempo parece más simple de lo que
es en el sentido de que los debates a
veces se sobre simplifican los sistemas
energéticos que ya están instalados
funcionando es difícil cambiarlos en sí
mismo sin embargo hoy en día existen
nuevos incentivos económicos
provenientes de distintos fondos y hay
más conocimientos técnicos y menores
menores riesgos a nivel inversiones que
permiten o facilitan a hacer esos
cambios de todos modos como dije antes
lleva más tiempo de lo que uno imagina
no es simplemente instalar los paneles
solares o una granja eólica eso también
tiene que ver con las cuestiones de las
redes de transmisión de la energía que
también tienen que ser resilientes a los
cambios en el clima es un poquito más
complejo de lo que parece pero es
importante si seguir en esa senda y
acelerarlo a lo más rápido posible es
complejo pero como como lo estábamos
hablando al ver o puedes empezar ya no
para que no se tarde tanto obviamente
ese proceso
exacto y también por otro lado al mismo
tiempo hay que estar haciendo cogiendo
las respuestas para el cambio que está
sucediendo es decir estos cambios en la
infraestructura energética van a tener
efectos a muy largo plazo sin embargo
los éxitos climáticos ya suceden hoy
álvaro muchísimas gracias como siempre
por acompañarnos en nuestras mañanas en
directo américa de francés de 4 un
abrazo muchísimas gracias raúl un abrazo
para toda la audiencia